Joining me today is an author,
the editorial director of the American
Institute for Economic Research as well
as a senior fellow at the Austrian
economic center.
Jeffrey Tucker.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me.
Good to be here.
I almost wore the same bow tie my
friend.
Really,
I should've brought one extra for you
that would have been working on this.
All right.
There's a ton I want to talk to you.
You're.
You're sort of a one of these people
that are right around all of the topics
that I'm talking about from freedom and
liberty and free speech and the battle
between the left and the right and all
that,
but your new book and I want to get the
title absolutely correct.
Right wing collectivism.
The other threat to liberty.
I thought that would be the spot for us
to kick this off because most of the
people watching this show know that I've
mostly focused on the left.
Sure,
sure.
Was My home or was it progressive?
I've woken up to it.
I shouldn't.
Real liberalism is obviously,
and that has nothing to do with the
modern left,
but sometimes people say,
Dave,
you don't critique the right enough.
So let's dive in.
What's interesting about talking about
is that so often the left and the right
are not as distinguishable as they seem
to be for,
for example,
uh,
the,
this,
this trade stuff.
You know,
Elizabeth Warren and Donald trump
basically agreed.
How do you account for that?
And now we use all the celebration of
the working classes.
You know,
you're going to get again,
uh,
the trump,
Ian Wright a green with a Bernie Sanders
on,
on that,
uh,
the left is evermore trending
nationalist and its immigration
policies,
for example,
that didn't use to be the case.
So how is the left?
Well,
well,
like Bernie Sanders complained that free
free immigration is,
is a coke or coke industries plot
basically to provide the capitalist
class cheaper workers for example,
now that you would have never found
anybody on the left 20 years ago saying
that,
but,
but now you know what's happening,
you know,
the,
the hatred of the,
of,
of commerce.
And,
and the merchant class is so intense now
that if a luxury resort in in Florida
wants to hire some,
some immigrants to work for them,
then the left is saying,
oh no,
this is,
this is terrible because his capitalist
capitalism at work.
So he was trying to see the strange
blending.
The left and the right have different
cultural pitches,
a different appeals,
different constituencies,
but they both have this agenda.
That's.
That boils down to the,
to the use of power.
Is this a little bit of just what people
refer to as the horseshoe theory,
that the more that the sides had become
sort of extreme,
that they're oddly,
that I've heard this,
this horseshoe.
I tend to think that's a little bit
superficial.
I mean I look at it a little bit more
historically and you see since since
liberalism was born in the world in the
18th century,
really high middle ages,
but when the revolt against liberalism
began the early 19th century,
right?
Too much change,
too much wealth.
The wrong people are getting rich and
there's not enough control.
What are we gonna do about our religion,
our language,
our rates?
You know,
the,
the revolt began to grow from about the
18,
20 isn't and intensified and spread to
the United States.
Britain really began to take root and
continental Europe.
There took two forms.
There was a left forearm and a right
form,
and in each country they took.
They took on different generations,
different names he knows so.
So in Britain you had the Tories,
then you had the Labor Labor Party.
They both wanted to use the state for
their own purposes.
Then you always had the opposition
party,
which was the liberals,
you know,
and,
and that's the way it's fleshed out
itself.
In country after country,
the Liberal Party has always been.
The people said,
why don't we just let society be,
let people live their lives.
Let them choose a religion of their own,
have their own choice.
If they don't hurt anybody,
that's not a problem.
Let's have free speech.
This have a universal rights as have
rights for this.
Get rid of slavery.
Let's have rights.
The acknowledged the existence of
women's rights or equality of freedom
for everybody.
Leave everybody alone.
That's the liberal position.
That's a pretty good position.
It's A.
It's a beautiful position and it's,
and it's what I favorites,
but I think it's what built civilization
coming out of the religious wars of the
high middle ages.
We discovered this idea of freedom.
We tried it,
it worked,
but there's.
But there's always been a revolt brewing
against it,
a resentment,
resentment against it or get resentment
against the commercial class.
Too much change,
too much wealth,
wrong.
People getting wealthy.
We're not controlling demographics well
enough.
There's not enough quality.
Whatever the thing is,
it takes different forms in different
countries and in different times in
different places,
but ultimately the right and the left or
ideologies of control and power and
liberalism has always been the
alternative to that.
So.
So we keep having to rediscover this
again and again and every generation.
Yeah,
well that's why now I'm so happy that
there is,
as you said to me right before we
started the phrase,
classical liberalism is coming back.
You know what I mean?
You hear it on tv every now and again.
I like to think that maybe I had a
little something to do with it,
you know,
and to me it is the only current
antidote to the problems that we have,
either the the more state power that the
democratic socialist want as they've
sort of ransacked their own party and
purged all of the Liberals and it's also
the antidote for all of the people.
If you think trump is all of the
horrible things that people say about
them all the time,
what's the antidote?
The antidote isn't to get somebody else
and then more power to power.
The antidote obviously is to take power
away from that.
That's what liberalism,
my hope is that,
that there are the good people left the
center of the left,
that we're looking at the emergence of
the trump problem.
We'll reconsider a the uses of power and
the executive state and why did we build
this gigantic machinery of the total
state if it's so vulnerable to being
captured by our enemies.
Right?
Right.
That's the real question that we're at
right now.
If you believe this thing has been
captured by the Russians or whatever it
is,
it's like,
well,
okay,
you're kind of answering your own
question.
I hope that we can,
we can rekindle a kind of a new
resurgence,
but I do have to credit you and Jordan
Peterson for this.
I mean,
I've been working at it for about 10
years to try to bring back to the,
not just the term liberal,
but the concept of liberalism to,
to public life and a bit.
It's been difficult because,
because,
because we do have the state that
creates a kind of moral and intellectual
and ideological hazard.
Somebodies got to control it.
And now that we,
we built it over the last hundred years,
this,
this total state,
massive taxes,
regulations,
interventions,
uh,
running people's lives.
Everybody's trying to get hold of it and
grab it and beat up their enemies.
And it's a problem.
It's a serious problem.
So when people say to me,
and we've discussed this on the show a
bunch of times before,
and I've addressed this in several
forums,
when people say to me,
wait a minute,
when you're,
when you say you're a classical liberal
in youtube about laissez faire economics
and getting the government out of the
way and all those things,
really this is just a repackaged
libertarianism or you're just afraid to
say that you're a conservative because
it's still not cool or something like
that.
How would you define the difference
between,
say,
a classical liberal and a libertarian?
Let's talk about that because,
uh,
because after World War Two,
these new,
these new terms came along,
uh,
one was conservatism.
It wasn't really used before the early
19 fifties,
Russell Kirk's book called,
uh,
the mindset of a conservative,
simply like the conservative mind,
I think it was what it was called.
And Libertarianism was again a first
used it about 1957.
Um,
by the translator of the works of
Basquiat.
The problem was the term liberal had
been captured by the new dealers as
early as 1933.
Once they acquiesced to the idea of the
corporate of estate and we're blaming
the great depression on capitalism,
um,
that became a problem for liberalism
that kept the term liberalism,
but they were no longer liberal because
they were suddenly for big government,
there were four big government and even
worse the corporate state.
And actually we can just be more blunt
about it and say that back in the 1930,
this,
this ideology had a name.
The name is fascist.
Okay.
So,
so the caved,
right.
I mean in the New York Times in 1933,
the New York Times magazine was
celebrating the great prep professor,
Mussolini and how he and FDR shared a
vision for the planned economy.
So that's the world we're living in back
then.
So we,
we lost the term liberal after World War
Two.
There was an attempt to,
to just speak a language,
to describe who we are.
And on one hand you had this new thing
called conservatism and they,
they,
they kind of sampled some of this Tori
Tori,
like nostalgia for the past,
a little bit of revanchist let's
recapture what we've lost.
Then you,
on the other hand,
you had the genuine liberals and they
coined the term libertarianism,
which had been sitting on the shelf
since the late 19th century.
Now most of the people who call
themselves libertarians in the late 19th
century,
America and England were anarchists,
socialists,
but nobody had bothered with the term
for decades and decades.
So Dean Russell said,
well,
nobody's using that word.
Why don't we use it?
And that was closer to the truth of what
they were in effect.
Well,
what was interesting about that is as
dean rustled described it in his 1957
article,
it was a synonym for what was once
called liberal.
He didn't think it was a tweak or an
improvement or a distillation or
refinement or a new dogmatic way of
describing liberalism.
He thought it was liberalism.
So I need to read that because I mean,
that's how I feel.
I don't.
If someone sends me,
Dave,
you're a libertarian.
I don't mind that.
If we need labels,
I don't mind that late.
I don't mind the idea.
You know,
we can split the difference on how much
government.
Sure,
she'd be the problem.
I think libertarianism as a number,
as a term,
has a number of problems.
One is it's a little clinical sounding
and it has too many syllables and it
makes you sound a little bit awkward and
it sounds maybe a little too canonical.
You know,
like we,
we have a list of things you have to
believe,
you know,
like this,
this,
it's all rooted in this kind of
reductionist.
A more commonly these days is rooted in
this kind of in a reductionist,
nonaggression principle,
which is a fine principles or rule of
thumb,
but it's not a good.
It doesn't describe the whole of life.
So the other problem is that
libertarianism is,
is a new term,
so it doesn't have a deep history.
So we can't look back and say,
oh look.
The Libertarians freed the slaves,
the libertarians a acknowledged to the
rights of women.
The Libertarians gave us,
the commercial society that built the
middle class and brought dignity to the
average person.
If they had existed as a party,
they would have done those.
They would have done this.
Well,
it means the liberals,
but it's deliberate.
We changed our name so now we can like,
feel a sense of pride in our past so it
doesn't have a past.
So that's a problem.
So we're at.
Libertarians tend to be detached from
their own history for that reason.
And I think it's a problem.
It's a word problem.
The second problem is that
libertarianism doesn't have a universal
of usage.
Like whereas liberalism does,
you can go to Spain,
describe yourself and liberal Brazil.
There's,
there's liberals in Germany,
there's liberals,
there's a word for liberalism and every
language and it more,
less means the same thing except in the
United States.
Right?
So,
uh,
so,
if we acquiesced to this term
libertarian and just wipe out our
liberal history,
we're cutting off cells off both from
the world and from our own history.
It's so funny because you've just said
it in a far better way than I think I've
ever really laid it out.
But people will say to me,
Dave,
stop saying you're a liberal and I don't
want to stop saying I get that.
I'm fighting an uphill battle right now.
Right.
I'm,
I'm a salmon swimming upstream.
This is going to be tough,
but I don't want to deny what is the
truth just because,
because it's tough.
It's who you are and you want to,
you want to have an ancestry,
you know,
you want to look back and,
and see,
uh,
the,
the champions are the medic cheese in
the 15th century,
Florence and say,
I know those people.
Those are my people.
You know,
the people who long for a world without
slavery,
you know,
in the early 19th century,
the people who wanted free trading
fought hard for it.
Those are our people.
That's our history.
I mean,
we were,
we were born as part of a long stream of
emancipation that's been taking place
for 500 years.
That's our movement,
our people,
our history.
Let's embrace it.
I'm with your brother.
Yeah.
Alright.
So are there any of those liberals,
a part of the Democratic Party anymore?
Do those people exist?
What's strange?
Things are happening on the left.
Very strange thing.
I'm not sure I should pause you for one
sec.
I my original question here because I
wanted to do the deep dive on that.
Right.
So we're going to get.
We will get.
No,
I promise you we're going to get to that
topic.
I mean,
the deep dive of the far right gets us
into a very dark place.
All right,
well maybe that.
so maybe the whole second half will be
on that,
but we just put that out there right
now.
That's what we'll do for this.
I'm just now getting out of my
depression having been a book.
It was terrible.
All right,
so our whole second half is going to be
what my first question was about.
Let's just keep going.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It would for now.
So,
so strange things have happened to the
left.
Um,
let's just mention that the phrase
cultural appropriation for example.
Now when,
when did that,
the approbation of this idea of cultural
appropriation can put two,
three years ago,
three,
four,
five.
I don't know,
academia is weird.
It may have been brewing for 10 years,
but when I first heard about it,
I thought that is the craziest bunch of
nonsense I've ever heard.
I mean,
civilization is nothing but cultural
appropriation.
We've been doing this since,
since the 19th century.
You know,
at the,
at the height of the competency and
Spain where Judaism and Islam and
Christianity came together in this
beautiful melting pot where we all learn
from each other and the cultures began
to blend and our religions began to
change at our.
Alright,
I'll look on life began to because we
learned from each other.
If we stay isolated in our little
tribes,
we're never going to progress and and,
and the idea that,
and I don't know if it was inadvertent
or what happened,
but we can talk about this,
but the,
when,
when suddenly you're told you cannot
have affection for another culture and
take what you find valuable and,
and learn,
learn for yourself and live a better
life.
That is very strange.
They seem to think it's cultural
annihilation,
not cultural appropriation,
right?
Like they seem to be.
This is something that will lead to the
destruction of that culture when in fact
it actually spreads the ideas of
culture,
the foods,
the thing,
the,
the ideas,
not just creating culture as a scarce
good like it's a property,
but it's not the magic of culture,
which is the same magic of ideas is
resides in its infinite reproducibility
and its malleability.
This is something that the world of
ideas can do that the physical world
cannot do,
and if we don't make that distinction,
we're going to get very confused.
Do you see what I mean?
Emily?
Cultures Spread and the,
they're infinite and they can constantly
change and that's the magic and beauty
of,
of culture and we can't get that out of
this glass of water,
this table,
right?
They're,
they're,
they're bound by the constraints of
scarcity.
But the world of ideas is,
it's magical.
It's like a constant,
constant,
infinite sandstorm,
you know,
unpredictable.
And I'm constantly changing and we can,
we can take a culture for ourselves
without taking it from somebody else.
Right?
It's just,
it's,
it's reproductive reproduction.
It's infinite reproduction.
So loaves and the fishes isn't,
isn't the beauty to that America has
done this better than anyone perhaps in
the history of the world.
You just referenced some other points in
time,
but that we have taken in more cultures.
And you said the phrase melting pot.
I mean that.
That's what we designed and set up here,
the most beautiful melting pot ever.
I lived in New York City for most of my
life,
most of my adult life at least,
and would be on subway cars.
And you are on that car with absolutely
everyone with have white guys with
dreadlocks and the whole thing.
And guess what?
You may not like everybody and you may
not like the way this guy smells and
that person may be doing this,
but we're all there living together.
It's magic.
You know,
it's,
it really,
it's commerce.
It's because this country elevated the
commercial ethos to be the highest thing
that great and no bling factor of,
of,
of human life.
And it's commerce that brings people
together.
And we experienced that every day.
You know,
you can,
in a commercial setting,
uh,
people aren't fighting each other,
they're getting along.
I mean,
I find I'm with you.
I go to,
I go to a restaurant and I get served by
some guy from,
from uh,
Pakistan.
It's a chance to meet somebody new.
It's a chance to engage somebody and I
have a personal relationship with
somebody who's serving you and you're
serving them.
And you experienced this magic of
exchange.
A Benjamin consultant used to talk about
this and the and the 18 thirties,
how,
how commerce brought to the world and
new understanding of freedom and a new
opportunity for us to find value in each
other,
in service of each other and see.
And America just flourished in commerce.
And that's why.
That's why we have,
you know,
the diversity and the end.
This melting pot they call it.
And this rich cultural life.
You know,
it's so funny because I'm so keenly
aware of it right now.
Not only because of the conversations
I'm having and because people are
screaming about this stuff all the time,
but you know,
I'm on this tour with Jordan Peterson
and when I go to every airport that I go
to,
I,
90 percent of the time,
unless someone's had a car for me,
I take an uber and I just happened
whatever rubric and there is there,
there is every single type of person
that looks every which way color every
sexuality.
And usually I talk a little bit to,
to them it's,
you know,
and it's like,
man,
these are just people,
you know,
I'm maybe for the same way,
I live in Atlanta,
which is just a gigantic really diverse
society,
you know,
and everywhere you go you're bumping
into people who are different from you
and,
and hang around and crypto circles in
Atlanta.
I want to talk to you and that you're
talking about a melting pot.
I mean we're all together and there are,
we all consider each other are people,
you know,
just because we all love crypto and it
has nothing to do with,
with race.
You can appreciate racial differences
with,
but also see value in everybody and hope
they can see value in you.
You can come together.
It doesn't mean that we have to be
egalitarian or,
or denied differences.
It means that we find strength and our
heterogeneity and,
and that's,
that makes for a beautiful and exciting
life.
One of the strangest things that's
happening now with the rise of the
outright in response to the failures and
strange and so the left is this new
celebration of homogeneity as if,
oh,
we need to live in a unitary racial
state,
you know,
where we all speak the same language are
all the same religion.
So that strikes me as this theoretically
very boring and I don't,
I don't even recognize what that world
would look like and feel like and it
doesn't appeal to me in the slightest
bit.
Yeah.
My nerdy.
It was built out of the,
out of the diversity that grows out of
commerce and the commerce is the key
because that's what helps us invest in
each other.
You know,
Adam Smith said this about the division
of Labor,
right?
It's like what causes wealth?
The division of Labor,
how big can that be?
It should be as big as possible.
The wider the division of Labor,
the more people you include in the great
project of of building commercial life
and production,
the wealthier we're all going to be
together and I just,
I love that vision.
So when
we talk about capitalism,
I,
they show I'll every now and again I
jumped in the comment section or I see
what people say on twitter.
If I have,
you know,
some of the Iran on or just some of the
people
that are not for regulation at all and
just let the economy go and see what
happens.
There's always a certain amount of
people that say,
okay,
that all sounds well and good,
but then the rich keep getting richer
and the poor keep getting poorer and
Jeff Bezos shouldn't have,
you know,
$20,000,000,000,000
or whatever he has right now are the
rest of it.
What's the,
what's the boiler plate answer to why
you eventually end up with those kind of
cliche.
It's because they've been,
they've been around for 150 years and
they've never been true.
I mean that they weren't true and
Marxists time and everybody quickly
recognize that going to by the late 19th
century in America,
we had,
we had built the most prosperous economy
in the world by far,
by far,
by far growing incomes,
longer lives,
healthier people,
more opportunities for everybody.
People are moving to the cities.
Everybody's benefiting from capitalism.
That's been going on for such a long
time.
Yet here we are in 2018 and we're still
recycling these,
these Victorian era cliche.
It's about capitalism.
I don't understand it.
What do you think capitalism then
screwed up if if only just a marketing
piece of it or something where right now
you sent and I believe that it will not
win.
It somehow doesn't seem cool to be for
capitalism,
at least with the.
He does seem to be the the change.
Maybe it's in the name and I.
I don't even have a problem not using
the word capitalism.
I mean I will probably have the same
view towards this.
I will speak the language that you can
understand and if I want to rebrand
capitalism as liberalism,
which it probably should be actually
liberal liberalism,
then I'm,
I'm glad to talk about that.
Same time.
I kinda liked the term capitalism.
I have no problem with capital because,
because it,
it really does underscore really
important point that without private
property and the in the and ownership of
the means of production,
you can't have a complex production
structures and you can't hire more
people.
You can't,
you can't build great things.
You can have great cities.
You can't improve people's lives.
So what are the things that you think
government should do?
Well,
I think of lots of clans rules that we
should have.
Um,
but I'm not a fan of governments in
general.
If there was some way that you could
have,
you know,
an old fashioned the state,
that was really minded,
his own business and um,
kept kept civil war from happening,
for example,
you know,
kept conflict,
that kind of mass conflict.
Um,
then that would be a probably a good,
a good thing.
Um,
state is not very good at that.
So,
um,
I,
I think,
I mean I've got,
I've got the mind of an addict because
to essentially I trust,
I trust the chaos of,
of spontaneous human action much more
than any kind of,
of,
of imposition.
Yeah.
But,
but I'm at same time,
I do like the writings of the old
liberals,
you know,
they,
they imagine that the state should do
something to keep something like order
in life to keep civil war from
happening,
to keep people from killing each other.
A terrible things like that.
But beyond that state should just,
it should be a laissez faire.
It should just allow commerce to
flourish and allow,
allow problems to work themselves out.
I am.
People don't have confidence in that
anymore,
but not because of any failure,
but it's almost like the ideology of
power has become a kind of a modern
cancer that affects a flicks everyone.
And I think we need to do something
about it.
Wait,
can you explain that a little bit?
Well,
it's just a.
Once you believe that you can control
the path of history and you have an
endpoint in mind,
society should look like this.
Then you want to use every kind of tool
to hammer it in place.
And this is what I called right and left
wing who galleon agonism essentially.
And it's,
it's a grave temptation.
And so we built this,
like we said at the outset,
and we built this gigantic machinery we
call the state this total state and a
control.
So much wealth and so much power and so
much rests with,
with,
uh,
getting,
you know,
gaining access to it,
that it just a kind of a constant moral
hazard for everybody,
like,
give,
give me that state and I'll make it do
the right things.
So for the people that are on either
side of this,
whether you're on the left and,
and you want to help those that you deem
have pressed more people with less when
I believe their intentions to be good,
even if their methodology I think
generally is not good.
Or your people on the right that want
less of the state.
But you know,
you're just on either side of this
thing.
How much do you think the system itself
can move without breaking?
Because what I think I'm noticing now is
that there's a certain amount of people
that really just want to trash the whole
thing and I do see this certainly more
on the left right now because they're
not empower that there's this growing
thing and this is why they're so into
Marxism and all this stuff now.
It's like let's just trash the whole
freaking thing and forget all the
goodness that this is done.
And they're doing it from their iphones
and you know,
their sense of irony is not great,
but is there,
is there,
is there just a certain amount that,
a system that's basically good can move
before it snaps?
And I,
I would suspect that that's not much
either way really.
Uh,
you mean the commercial structure?
Right now our lives are capitalist
structures.
I mean the state,
um,
you know,
what I see actually happening is the
innovation has taken place so quickly.
It's actually out running.
They have the capacity of government to
control it.
And I think that's,
that's really exciting if I was going to
look at one point of hope in the world
and set the market and the
entrepreneurial innovative sectors of
life from the APP economy to the Gig
economy to now with blockchain
technology and everything is moving so
quickly that states can't,
can't even keep up.
Right.
So I'm there with you on that because
Gloria.
So I'm very happy about that.
I don't see that because it's.
To me it's like how are people listening
to all of these conversations,
all of these podcasts that are out there
and communicating about them so quickly
and it's like the government can't.
I can't keep up with all of that.
The change can't because people are
lighting up all the time now in a much
faster way.
And I think we're changing in a much
more rapid way and I think that's
actually really cool.
There's a danger to it because we could
just spin out of control and do all
sorts of awful things.
But what you said,
well,
what did you say before about the
general inertia of people or something
that the general left to their own ways
of figuring things out?
I figured it out.
The reason why our politics seem
reactionary on the left and the right.
Everyone's trying to bring back
something.
There's a nostalgia on the left and then
establish a on the right and they're
trying to use the state to hold us back
like in and whatever.
It's a vision of the.
Is it the sixties?
Is it,
is it the seventies?
Is it preindustrial revolution,
you know,
is at some risks.
So he and fantasy of perfect equality
and the,
the left might imagine,
or,
or the ride,
uh,
thinking about,
you know,
a world of high tariffs of the 18,
eighties or nineties are.
But everyone's looking back to something
that they want to create and there's a
real fear of the future and the left and
the right.
And as a future without control,
it's a future where we're able to
travel,
where we want to download the apps.
We want to invent what we want to work
by ourselves,
live where we want to live,
be digital nomads,
you know,
travel around,
do it.
We want this,
this world.
That's not what people should be.
Fewer people.
Everyone should be going,
holy cow,
this is the free is coolest thing ever.
That's the world I want to live in.
I want to live.
That obviously is why you're so
attracted to bitcoin and crypto in
general because you're sort of the
backbone.
Well out of this.
I mean if you think about it,
I mean we've waited our whole lives and
actually generations of great
intellectuals have lived and lived and
died for so long,
wanting something like a private
currency that,
that emerged privately,
that operates without financial
intermediaries,
that the government is not controlling
that it's global.
That doesn't.
It's not restrained by currency zones
that anyone could have access to.
You know,
a true democratic technology like
bitcoin or any cryptocurrency.
That is just a dream come true.
That is Gloria.
That's why I write about it all the time
and talk about it all the time.
It is,
it is the outright killer.
It is the alt left killer.
It's,
it's the thing that's going to
ultimately,
I think,
protect us from these wicked ideologies
that are constantly trying to control
their lives
because basically at some point one of
these ideologies is gonna get too much
control of the state forever.
I mean,
you know,
one of the things that I think about
this sometimes when you get depressed
about the divisions in our public life
and the way people are tearing,
tearing each other apart and the way you
opened up the newspaper and this,
you can barely even read it anymore.
You know,
it was like,
yeah,
I know.
I know,
but it's like Donald Trump.
You then just like,
you know,
I'll put trump,
and it's just,
it's just this forever debate.
And the one thing that I think maybe we
should not be entirely unhappy about
this.
As you look back at history,
when,
when freedom emerges out of the high
middle ages,
it wasn't because any one great
intellectual or anyone great state or
anyone great power said,
hey,
let's let everybody be free.
It was because there's so many
competitors for power.
They nobody could,
could gain the monopoly was the church,
it was the,
the nation state,
it was the localities and monarchical
state,
uh,
the,
the landed aristocracy,
you know,
the,
the rise of the merchant class,
you know,
so there are all these independent power
centers strewn throughout European
society and nobody could get,
get access to the finals,
single singular control,
no unitary power.
And that fight that took place amongst
so many disparate powers to actually
lead to a kind of flourishing of
freedom.
So you know,
in a sense the fight between the left
and the right today is not the worst
thing.
If they just keep fighting and leave the
rest of us alone.
I don't know where we're going to be
that lucky,
but okay,
so before we spend the whole second half
on the question that I started this
whole thing with the people who want
freedom basically,
and a light touch of government,
are they always at a disadvantage
because there's another set of people
who will always use the apparatus
against them where if they're being true
to themselves,
they won't use the power to stifle other
people.
There were all sorts of other things,
so in an odd way our ideas are at a
disadvantage,
always have been.
We've always been a kind of minority.
So even again,
over the last two or 300 years of
political history have always been the
third way.
That's fine,
man already.
But we had,
we had rare victories,
but big ones,
you know,
like the end of slavery,
um,
was just glorious.
I mean the protection of the great
banking empires of Europe from,
from the populace rabble,
you know,
from the,
from the preachers who wanted to destroy
it.
There were these great victories of the
victory of free trade,
you know,
but,
but we've won every once in a while and
it always changed the world because once
we have a little bit of freedom just a
little bit,
it just blows up and it becomes awesome
and it's amazing and it.
And it kills power because it's so
powerful and so wonderful.
But it's worth fighting for.
And we've always fought mainly through
ideas,
not through armies,
not through through guns and controlling
states.
It's always been the philosophical
awesomeness of this position has been
the celebration of the common man,
uh,
the celebration of,
of wealth,
of the love of,
of consumerism and commercial life for
the coming together of people,
the noble meant of people that the right
of,
of travel,
the right of association,
and to do what you want to have as many
children as you want to educate your
kids the way you want to,
that these kinds of principles are
compelling and they've always lead to
victory for liberals despite the
pressure from the other two sides.
And I think it's,
I think it's going to be our future.
I do.
Let's shift.
Let's talk about the scary.
Right?
Are you ready?
I tried to do this and we adapted.
We did the happy stuff.
Now we're going to plunge to look.
You know,
David,
when I began to research this thing,
I probably ended up reading about 200
books on this topic when the end and,
and I'm a happy guy.
I like happy things like technology.
I'm an optimistic guy,
but this really put me in a dark place,
a digging through this history,
uh,
from,
from Hagle,
essentially up to Julius Caesar,
Eveleigh and the,
and the post were Nazi movement and
realizing that there is an intellectual
strain that stretched over all of these
years.
Let's go back 200 years.
Yeah.
So let's go back 200 years when you talk
about right wing collectivism.
Yeah.
Because I think most of my audience now
understands what left wing collectivism
is because that's what we've got right
now.
Very in a very strong way.
Talk to me about right wing
collectivism.
Okay.
Dave,
I'm going to tell you a story.
Um,
I,
I love Ludovico muses.
I think it was a genius,
right?
And I thought I'd read all of his works,
but in there is a transcript of a
lecture he gave in 1956 at the San
Francisco Public Library and he had
about three sentences in there that just
knocked me over it and I couldn't
believe it because it explained so much.
He says something like this and he's
speaking casually,
right?
It says,
hagle ruined German philosophy for a
century.
Uh,
his original followers became a,
W,
believed that all of history would end
in the Prussian state and the Prussian
church having all power and the
individualism,
they became the right hit galleons that
became the Nazis is the dissonance of
this,
uh,
of the writer.
Galleons became the left to galleons.
They wanted a universal transformation
of humanity and a historical drive to
something other than the commercial
society.
They became the Marxists and,
uh,
and the communists.
And he said that that's it's left,
right Galleon ism and that explains
pretty much all the political history.
And I closed that.
I thought that explains more than
practically any other book I've ever
read.
And so I began to,
began to explore this.
I understood the left together.
I understood Marxism.
I mean,
those were,
those were our professors,
right?
Um,
and they're annoying.
Uh,
but what I did not understand was the
right who galleon ism and what that,
what that tradition looks like.
It's the throne.
And alter this,
this historic view that the nation
should constitute its own unit of
profound integrity,
uh,
that,
that is more important than the,
than the individual.
And that commercial society was too
chaotic,
that it,
that,
that it was leading us,
giving us the wrong kind of progress,
that it was flattening out the
hierarchies that we need to have an
orderly life,
right?
This is,
this is the right who galleon pitch that
ultimately by mid 20th century becomes
this very dangerous,
dangerous movement in Europe,
you know,
um,
became catastrophic,
uh,
but it gradually emerged from all the
way from,
from Hagle because,
uh,
this is at the end of the endless,
seemingly endless Franco pressure
awards.
There's this battle of the battle of
Jenna that,
that Germany lost.
And the explanation for that was that
was a temporary setback.
That history,
it was going to determine that Germany
would rise just despite,
despite the choices and individual's
history has got its wind.
It's like a Meta narrative that,
that,
that was going to override everything.
Hegel himself was a theologian by the
way.
Um,
and,
and so this,
this view began to kind of spread
throughout German academia and it was,
it ended up being important to the
United States through,
through circuitous means,
but what,
but one of the great theorists of the,
of the team forties,
who am 18 fifties,
who brought the suit to the United
States was Frederick List,
who was one of the first economist to
repudiate the free trade tradition of,
of,
of the Smithian a Manchester Rights.
And now we're celebrating the nation as
a,
as a unit,
as a productive power,
uh,
and,
and believed in tariff walls,
uh,
which was strange and I've read his
book,
uh,
but,
and that had a huge influence over
American trade policy is actually the
late 19th century.
And,
um,
and it,
it began to flow out from there.
So Thomas,
Carlyle,
and,
and in Britain now begins to celebrate
the great man theory of history.
And really we're nothing without
Napoleon,
without,
without gigantic figures that we can
worship at Meijer.
And individuality should be subsumed
within them.
They act for us,
God like,
you know,
and,
and it was Thomas Carlyle who first
coined the phrase,
I'm a coined the phrase to describe
economics as being the dismal science.
And the reason he said that is that
every economist,
team new,
imagined a world without slavery,
and he said you to have a website
slavery,
that's a dreadful world without slaves,
you don't have masters,
right?
And we need a world with masters and
slaves so we can,
we can have a vision of hierarchy and
greatness without that,
we don't have greatness.
So we began to see this building of this
intellectual apparatus that was not left
to galleon.
There wasn't Marxist,
Anti Marxist in a strange way,
but as an alternative form of
collectivism,
uh,
it,
it began with a kind of historicism and
a celebration on nationalism with a
German stayed,
began to grow with this,
this,
this alternative theory of trade that we
should,
we should build up tariff walls.
And Carlisle with his,
with his great man theory of history.
And then,
and then,
uh,
Rueskin and Britain with his haste hate
hatred of Commercial Society because
they believed that somehow a commerce
which ruined in quality and culture and
was giving us mass production and by we
all need to be really doing this is,
is a,
uh,
living in guilds and making our own
stuff,
you know,
because we're going to destroy English
life and English country life.
And so,
so a full scale reactionary trend on the
right began to develop.
And it was always a racial element to
know.
So that's what's interesting.
I'm so glad you asked that because it
comes about,
first of all,
through,
through nationalism now and the end,
the early 18,
20,018
thirties,
this celebration of nationalist.
Now you have to ask yourself,
what is a nation?
What do we mean when we say nation?
And,
and I'm taking this,
a lot of this from a,
from a,
uh,
an essay gave it given to 1882 by Aaron
ran in a great French historian,
uh,
looking back at the rise of nationalism.
So there's only five ways you can
consider nationalism.
You consider,
uh,
the geographic definition,
so we're just living in this space.
There's a dynastic element.
We can all trace our lineage back to the
great founders of our nation.
There is a language theory of
nationalism.
We all speak the same language.
There's a religious theory of
nationalism all worship a god and a
precisely the same way.
I believe in transubstantiation.
You believe in consubstantiation we
can't be part of the same nation and
that gates.
Right?
And then finally,
and probably most insidiously,
there was a racial,
the racial view,
and that came along and essentially the
18,
sixties and seventies with a
misapplication of Darwinian theory and
scientific racism came along.
And that's wet through academia,
particularly in the United States,
like nothing you've ever seen.
It was absolutely astonishing how much
racism with Orthodoxy and American
academia in the 1890 [inaudible],
some of the very first monograph
published by the American Economic
Economic Association,
Black Gay man,
I think his name is Andre Hoffman,
was called race traits of the American
Negro.
And the first chapter dress goes all in.
You know,
it's,
it's the horror of the black people that
don't have the right values,
that can't,
can't save money,
they're just terrible.
A shiftless and lazy and ghastly and
uncivilized,
double.
And now chapter two,
the Jews,
you know,
these people,
I don't know what they've got this crazy
out of control commercial ethic.
They can't stop hoarding money.
They really went for it.
Yeah.
And then the third chapter three is the
slots and so on.
And so the American Economic
Association,
you know,
and then,
uh,
and there was essentially no,
what do you think was happening in the
world there?
That it was taking a time,
what was happening,
David Laissez faire had transformed
society so dramatically that the
intellectuals felt that they had lost
control and now you might think that
when the world becomes massively
prosperous and we suddenly have cities
rising up and we've got steel that
transversing large bodies of water and
we're developing the telephone and
indoor electricity and,
and people are living longer lives and,
and so much wealth is being created that
everybody was data per say.
Hooray.
We found the answers,
but the gatekeepers who had controlled
everything for so long.
So that's so interesting because of
revolt.
This is sort of what it feels like now
to me,
the gatekeepers,
we've had so much success.
There's so many,
there's so many reasons right now to
understand how great everything is.
That book right there by Steven Pinker,
enlightened misery is all about how
great things are and how grateful we
are.
There is less violence now and all sorts
of the.
And so the revolt you always have to be
on like the gatekeepers are having when
the narrative intellectuals or what
Deirdre mccloskey calls the clerisy,
right?
So it's the high end intellectuals,
it's the power elite bureaucrats and the
public,
the permanent peace keepers of our civic
culture.
You know,
it's,
it's the political class.
And uh,
so this is sorta what for,
for my audience that maybe not follow
this.
This is sort of what the New York Times
is sort of like.
Yeah,
maybe I shouldn't have said it.
So obviously.
But like that's kind of what it is.
Like that class,
the ruling class,
and they were in full scale revolted.
They did not like what was happening to
the world and the 18,
eighties and nineties because of the
loss of control.
And so the,
the scientific racism came along to add
to the celebration of dictatorship and
the and the and protectionism and the
new nationalism to add a very insidious
element which culminated in eugenics
ideology.
And that's when it gets very strange.
And this is where,
this is where the reading gets very
difficult because now you're reading all
the way into a,
you know,
the,
the 19th tens with the works of Oswald
Spangler,
you know,
the,
the right who galleon German theorist
that enraptured every American,
you,
they're all reading his book,
Oh my God,
the decline of the West.
We better reconstitute ourselves as the
tribe or we're going to be eaten alive
by another four.
And then there's a strain of that that's
still going on right now.
There is nothing new,
you know,
like,
um,
and you know,
the,
this,
this very funny book called the passing
of the great race by Madison grant that
was on every coffee table in the late 19
teens and early 19th,
20th,
you know,
was,
was forecasting doom for the white race,
you know,
when he was,
he was a fascinating figure because,
um,
you know,
of course I've read his book as,
as it everybody did.
Everybody a great gatsby makes a passing
reference to it.
It was that popular,
it was that popular.
And I tell you there's not a single
outright racist alive today who hasn't,
is not repeating those cliches that were
written by Madison.
Grant is all pseudoscience is all just
nonsense and it's just ridiculous and
embarrassing.
But,
but it keeps being resurrected.
But here's what's interesting,
he was a thoroughgoing a Darwinian
because she recall that Darwin had two
great books,
origin these pieces.
The other was called the descent of man.
And the descent of man had the very
unfortunate paragraph in there where he
gret regrets,
um,
the invention of mass,
a disease killing a,
uh,
a juror's essentially.
It's like if we keep curing people and
we keep feeding a inferior people and
curing disease than then our genetic
stocks going to go down and down,
you know,
so,
so they are all kind of playing off this
little passage,
but Madison grant was,
was not an unusual by American x to
academic standards at all.
They,
they.
This was orthodox in the 18,
10,
19 twenties.
What made Madison Grant Interesting?
You can look up his wikipedia entry
right now.
Uh,
if you look it up,
it'll,
it'll celebrate him as the,
as the father of the National Park
Service.
Well,
in the course of my research,
I wondered to know what is the
connection between Madison's grants,
hardcore,
eugenics based racism and its
environmental design.
What is the relationship there?
Remember,
it's not just two people.
Usually people have,
have it figured out in their own head.
So I went through and read some of his
works on,
on the environment.
It turns out that he had a master race
theory of nature and he went to the
California redwoods and he looked at
these glorious mighty trees and he was
horrified to see they're being cut down
for,
for making coffee tables and boats and
things like that.
And you thought it was this gigantic to
nature.
So he wanted the master race,
uh,
the California redwoods to,
to be protected.
And that's that.
So that's why he started the national
park service.
And now the left heroism is as great as
a great visionary environmentalist.
But actually he was like a tree Nazi.
I don't know how else you want to go.
It's very creepy stuff.
We don't have enough Nazi labels being
thrown around.
Now we're going to have tree nuts.
I'm sure that already was nuts.
Um,
but you know,
you can just march through the history
and it gets worse and worse.
And then to me,
Dave,
it'll,
it'll culminates in the works of Carl
Schmidt,
uh,
from the,
from the late 19 thirties and his,
and his amazing book called the concept
of the political.
And if you'll give me just one quick
second to explain this,
because because you as a liberal need to
read this book because it's the most
passionate,
I would say,
an even competent attack on liberalism
Britain in the 20th century.
Now,
Carl Schmidt,
what's a jurist?
A brilliant man and a philosopher and a
hardcore Nazi.
Okay.
He wasn't tried at Nuremberg.
He escaped.
I'm merely an intellectual.
Okay?
Sure.
His book concept of the political.
What's wrong with liberalism?
I tell you,
it's dull.
Nothing happens,
nothing dramatic.
There's nothing.
Just requires no courage whatsoever.
Liberalism is a life in which we all
benefit from each other's presence.
We all just trade with each other.
What kind of life is that?
Where we all just are kind of the same
and like each other and help backyard
barbecues and baseball games and just
get richer and live longer lives and
send their kid to college.
This is terrible.
We need to live big,
dramatic,
mighty,
bold,
courageous,
transformative lives,
and live in times that,
that,
that are shocking,
that are amazing,
that make our lives worth living.
That requires above all else politics.
Liberalism imagines a world without
politics,
that's a terrifying world.
What we need is a world of politics and
and he continues to lay it out chapter
by chapter,
why we have to destroy liberalism and
celebrate the concept of the political
and for him that means having friends
and having enemies,
defeating your enemies and rallying
around your friends.
Now who are your friends and who your
enemies and mode says at some level it
doesn't matter.
What matters is that they exist and and
the state,
the powerful men will choose them for
us.
They will decide who our friends and our
enemies are.
Now let's be clear what we mean by
enemy.
I don't stop me in somebody you don't
like.
I mean the willingness to kill.
There has to be the presence of real
bloodshed in your time.
For you to have a sufficiently prescient
sense of enemies so that you'll feel the
intense desire to rally around your fin
for your friends and experienced that.
That the,
the,
the awesomeness that only comes with
belonging to a group.
So,
so he says,
so he,
at the end,
the end feeling there is that you can't
achieve what,
what the real purpose of a humanist.
That's right,
that you can experience whatever,
the highs of belongingness essentially
and,
and the life of drama that a big
important life without being part of a
kind of a,
a group on the move,
the slaughtering of center.
And so we have to have the presence of
bloodshed.
So it really is the opposite of live and
let live it is.
It's so through,
through,
through bloodshed comes life and
without,
without bloodshed and death and violence
and politics,
then you're just gonna live at an
irrelevant life and we can't have that.
So he was in many ways of philosophical
architect of the Holocaust.
Again,
not a leftist,
not a Marxist,
although he dabbled in it.
You find that.
So from a lot of these right
collectivists the writer galleons that
they dabbled,
guys like verner,
sambar writings,
wants a communist who later became a
Nazi.
Carl Schmitt dabbled in and leftism and
then went full,
right?
Um,
and it,
it was in many ways the culmination to
the right hand galleon ideology and the
encroachment.
So it's a book worth reading and
contemplating.
And I would say to anybody who rejects
liberalism,
you know,
be honest about where you're going with
this.
This is the opposite of liberalism,
the celebration of death and the quirks
of Schmidt,
very powerful thinker,
highly regarded even today worth reading
and worth reflecting on what kind of
world do want to live in.
Want to live in peace with others.
Where do you want to slaughter your
friends,
slaughter your enemies and rally with
your friends.
So move me from that point 19 thirties
into,
of course,
obviously into Nazi Germany and then
we'll,
we,
yeah.
And,
and you know,
my book really does end in 1958.
Not necessarily,
didn't have to,
but I,
I started to get really queasy about
what happened after World War Two.
A lot of the writer galleon movement
went underground,
you know,
um,
and,
and became a kind of a quiet neo Nazi
movement that never really had access to
social media.
They clearly weren't in academia,
obviously.
And but the ideology never entirely went
away and,
and it was just lying in,
wait,
waiting for the failure of the left and
for the resentment of the population
against the left to rise up and receive
a fevered enough pitch that it would,
it would then come on full force.
And that's really what's happening in
Europe.
Russia,
United States,
it's an alternative form of
collectivism,
has got a different flavor,
a different orientation at different
kinds of resentments,
but it still drags in this gigantic
history of writing Ghillean ideology.
That celebration of that Dick Great man
dictated the protectionism,
the anti-immigration,
the nativism,
the nationalism that could take any one
of five forms including the racism.
Um,
what do you make about how now?
And it's obviously largely because of
the Internet,
it seems to be happening in so many
places at once.
We're seeing this unholy.
It's an oddly unholy alliance between
the collectivist left and then that
drives,
I mean,
it's exactly what you're saying.
Then you've got this other data that's
just waiting there for these guys to go
to bananas.
And I was like,
ah,
we got all these answers.
Meanwhile,
you have the liberals and everyone,
all the decent 80 percent of us that are
trying to live in that part of it really
comes down to this.
There was a weird sociological,
cultural contradiction at the heart of
social democratic leftist ideology.
On one hand they they wanted to build
gigantic institutions that are
redistributed Tori and we're supposed to
treat each other like a big family and
we're supposed to have this homogeneous
nation state and the other hand they're
celebrating diversity and encouraging
mass immigration and heterogeneous
populations and guests,
but those don't really work together.
So you build gigantic institute,
gigantic states that presumed sort of.
We're all one family and then you throw
in this,
this,
this diverse set of people,
especially with the refugee crisis in
Europe and immigration in the United
States and people are looking around
going down,
these people are my family.
I don't even like these and yet I'm
paying for them and that is A.
I mean that that blows up.
I'm.
That's a disaster.
It's a powder keg and so is the left and
there's this core contradiction that
they have between on a welfare state.
On one hand and their celebration,
Hetero heterogeneous populations on the
other welfare state and diversity,
they don't,
they don't work.
And that basically puts us where Germany
sort of is at right now,
right where they said,
okay,
3 million people come on in now all
these people are going to have to pay
for you.
We're not going to integrate you
properly.
I mean this is not only to identitarian
movements rising up in Germany and in
Hungary and of course in Russia and of
course the US,
you know,
so it all just kind of follows.
It's,
it's inevitable.
The left created this.
I mean if,
if after World War Two,
we had just embraced liberalism by we
should have,
we should have,
we wouldn't be where we are today,
but we have another chance and that's
why you're here.
And that's why I'm here.
We have another chance now to re embrace
liberal liberal theory and to end to
reject the left.
Right?
And don't feel yourself just because of
the enemy of your enemy is,
is there.
It doesn't mean to ask to be your
friend.
I mean,
we really do need to think of ourselves
as kind of a distance from a political
culture that,
that rally around freedom and human
rights and universal human rights and,
and the enablement of humanity,
the champion of the common person,
uh,
the rights of everyone to live freely
with each other,
to,
to gain value from each other and to
live in peace and stop thinking of our,
of our fellow human beings as possible
enemies.
We don't want to get drafted into this
political world that Carl Schmitt.
Imagine for us,
as I was describing crossfit you,
you see it happening,
right?
That Schmidt,
Ian View to slice and dice the
population.
Who Do you like?
Who Do you hate?
You know,
who,
who are your people?
It's,
this is not a good life.
Yeah.
And we feel it chopping away at both
sides,
right?
Yeah,
we do.
We feel it.
And so we don't,
I just don't feel like we have to be
part of it as best we can.
Uh,
let's find things we love,
you know,
and go places we love me with people who
love of all different backgrounds,
all different kinds of cultures,
learn about alternative religions or
learn about new ways to do things.
Travel right.
And the age of liberalism.
There were no such things as passports,
you know.
All right,
so let's,
let's spend the last portion here on,
on just these last five years really
here in America because I remember just
even,
it doesn't have to be the last five
years,
but let's say even three years ago,
just it's sort of the emergence of trump
as a candidate when people started
saying the phrase,
all right.
Yeah,
and I did a bunch of videos on it where
I was basically saying I see two strains
to this thing and people are now using
this video against me.
And what I saw was there was the sort of
fun me makers and the.
I know all of the people who were having
fun online doing often doing awful
things and Nazi imagery just to,
to,
to upset people in power and whatever.
But sometimes it's very fun things too.
And funny things,
but I saw it like just the real sort of
shit posters they're known in the
gay people.
The whole idea was we could get,
we can start sending a frog to some like
intellectual and they're going to think
that's a racist thing.
And then they would,
they would say I'm being under attack
from racist.
They would actually give them exactly
what they wanted.
So I saw this,
this sort of fun shit posting whatever
part of it.
Not to say it didn't have elements I
didn't like,
but there were,
I saw that as the bulk of it.
And then alongside of that was this,
that you're talking about the
identitarian part,
the true racist part,
the part that had been sort of
underground for a long time and then
because of social media now is finding
that it could actually influence people
and beat it up.
Well,
okay.
So those.
And now and you know,
and I think the media really fueled both
of those things because basically when
Hillary said that deplorables comment,
she,
she just lumped the whole damn thing
together.
And I think if she had not said that,
I think it's very possible she be
president anyhow.
And she helped the country almost made
they'll write exists.
So it was what my question really is.
How would you just define the alt right
flat out,
if I asked you right now,
because I think the definition has
changed and has it.
But if I asked you right now in the
summer of 2018 to definition,
so you know,
the,
the phrase.
All right,
comes about what,
10 years ago,
I think it was coined by,
by Paul God prayed,
who himself as a follower of Carl
Schmidt,
um,
I,
I would rather look at this as a,
as,
as a writer,
Galleon collectivist movement,
you know,
and in general,
that stretches from the early 19th
century all the way up to the present
that's characterized by love of
dictatorship.
I love of power,
protectionist trade policy,
nativist immigration policy,
and an,
and a resentment against commercial
life.
Because it's because it's,
it's,
it's too heterogeneous.
Intuit and noble enough humanity.
I mean,
that's,
to me the alt right is one species.
I guess you could say one flavoring,
one instanciation
have a much larger problem that
stretches way back,
which isn't in liberal theory of,
of life in illiberal theory of,
of,
um,
uh,
politics.
So that's,
I think the right way to think about it.
My first time I heard trump speak was
July 2015 and I don't even think we were
using the term right at the time,
but he opened his speech with,
um,
immigrants are a problem.
I thought,
hmm.
Then there was protection of their
foreign goods,
protectionist when do protection,
something like that.
It was third big point was I can fix
everything.
This is all sounding strangely familiar
to me,
you know,
that's,
that's like the three pillars of a
writer Galleon ideology essentially.
And um,
I realized we had a problem and I
understand.
I do where people had a high regard for
him.
He was going to save us from,
from the problems that Obama had
created.
And God knows those problems and the
left has gotten just bonkers,
right?
So we need,
we need protection from that.
But he introduced his own form of
problems in the unleashed it's own form
of,
of dangerous and and potential punch.
Essentially despotic arrangements of
power and in some ways are more
insidious because they appealed to
bourgeoisie.
The left has always been a little bit
culturally estranged,
you know,
from,
from the mainstream of American life.
Whereas trump connects very closely with
it.
This is why fascist movements have been
oftentimes much more successful than the
left socialist once.
Wait,
I gotta I gotta get this because I would
have thought the opposite.
So if you,
if you would have asked me before you
said that,
I would say the left is the one that is
understood the culture part of this,
at least in the American piece of they
certainly academia and culture,
what you could and couldn't joke about.
Culture.
The left is as high.
You know,
socialist ideology never came from
below.
It was never working.
Man's philosophy,
it was always a mental.
I was always the intellectuals.
It was a top down rule was always the
ruling class that hatched associates,
socialist ideology that never would have
been communism,
socialism,
all those things without the
intellectual class.
But fascism,
if you'll allow me to use that term,
a kind of flip scenario to have a little
bit.
It's more,
it's much more of a from below it.
You can keep your religion,
you can keep your nationhood,
your identity,
your race,
your language,
rally around your friends,
your family,
you know,
all the things that you believe are
true.
You and,
and,
and within me as a person,
as a leader,
I will,
I will embody all your values and,
and collected by as us in a way that
that means something important that
connects with who you are.
So in that sense,
it's a very effective way of being
illiberal.
Alright?
So all that said,
what is our way out of this precarious
position?
I think I get where I get the theme of
what you're doing here is we have to
just keep fighting for what we've been
thinking better.
Well,
so dave,
I think we need to rethink who we are.
I think we need to deepen and enrich our
understanding of who we are and what
we're here to do,
and it goes back centuries.
I mean it was the liberalism that dog is
out of feudalism that ended the guilds
that brought us free trade,
that ended slavery,
that really gave birth to the modern
world and we need to learn to take
credit for that and make that ethos our
ethos.
Go back and read the works of Adam Smith
and the Great Scottish,
Scottish enlightenment thinkers.
You know,
and,
and understand our history so we
understand ourselves better.
I think this is important because we
need to stop thinking of ourselves even
though we are radicals.
I think you are.
I think I am.
I almost believe that we should stop
thinking of ourselves that way.
We should think of ourselves as normal.
If I'm a radical,
then the phrase radical,
it's definitely not as cool as it used
to be.
I mean,
I,
I think I'm open to these ideas and I
guess being,
being open right now and being really
living up to the ideals that you said
fourth year.
He's,
these days it kind of is,
and maybe liberalism has always been a
radical creed because it opposes power.
It always had been opposed to power.
That's where we have to do now,
but we also have to celebrate regular
life.
You know,
we have to.
We have to celebrate the good life and
the beautiful things and the things we
love,
the people we love and the choices that
we can make in the technologies that you
can use it.
I fall in love with the new technology.
Every single day I came over,
I came over to see you with this new
funny pillow that I bought for $10 on
Amazon and it allows me to sleep sitting
up and I'm been raptured.
But yeah,
I think this is the way to happiness and
I think ultimately is the path to
political victory for us to to be,
to be more hopeful,
to be more cheerful,
to be more,
to celebrate life and celebrate love and
celebrate.
Wow.
In a way in which neither left or the
right or doing right now.
It gives us as an opening to be awesome,
to emancipate the world.
We can do this.
I got nothing better to do for more
ride.
Jeffrey,
follow him on twitter.
Jeffrey a tucker.